hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm just juggling
all new
[Music]
just checking in on you how's it going
how's your thursday no seriously
how is it going
um
i'm uh i'm out here seeing the family
back east
doing some gigs
i'm in wilkes bar or wilkes-barre
pennsylvania
i don't know how you say it i've always
found pennsylvania [__] depressing
unless i'm in philly
or
if i'm in
pittsburgh there's just something about
driving
there's certain parts of the country i
don't know what the [__] it is
i think it goes back to
when
no one knew who the [__] i was
and i was just driving to some gig in
the middle of [__] nowhere
and i'd be driving out to like [__]
pennsylvania like upstate new york
i'm telling you right now you want to
see me in a bad mood get me on the
[__] 87 north
you know there's like there's some sort
of cutoff i don't know where it is
somewhere somewhere around
poughkeepsie
you know
and i just drive and what's funny is
both pennsylvania and new york are
[__] gorgeous
dude it's [__] god's country
lush green [__]
topography
you know
uh
all kinds of water on the geography
i'd go under an oath with the
stenography
sorry um
yeah they're [__] beautiful but
there's just something about it just
i remember getting on the 87 north one
time
oh my god i had this gig way in north
northern vermont
and jesus christ
you just rent a [__] car and you just
get in it and you just pointed at
montreal and you just started driving
and driving and driving and driving just
[__]
at some point
you banged a right over the [__]
hudson river
and then you were in vermont
and you're like oh wow this is going to
be great
doing a gig in vermont i never did stand
up for months sorry i just [__] woke
up
i never even did stand up every morning
check another state off the [__] list
oh billy ocd you gotta do a stand up in
every [__] state nine year old and i
know that can make everybody [__]
live that's what i did
all the way up
to vermont
and i was working in this uh
this hotel or some [__]
and i remember this guy was middling for
me
he was a nice guy and everything this
[__] [__]
was supposed to do like 20 minutes
you know friday night he did like 37
which is just way [__] over i mean
headlining was 45 minutes
back then on that gig
and this [__] [__] does 36 and
then he pulls the whole oh hey i'm sorry
i'm sorry i didn't know
about some [__] like that right
and the [__] next night he went out
he did close to like an hour
and all he was trying to do was burn out
the [__] crowd
so when i went up there there was like
nothing left
and i was so stupid i believed him on
the first show that he didn't he that he
accidentally did 37 minutes the [__]
guy was like 40 years old
back then jesus christ he's got to be
pushing 70 now
that's what's getting scary man that
[__] gig was almost 30 years ago
30 years ago here i am still bitching
about it
rather than [__] you know i should
just gone up there you know done the gig
got myself some syrup whatever whatever
souvenir
you know what the [__] you do i did some
shows there i'm in new york city uh
yesterday
i went to the matinee showing of
american buffalo
um
which was absolutely incredible
it's funny it's one of the few plays
that i actually know
um
remember a long
long time ago
i was taking
i was thinking of taking acting classes
that's what it was i didn't even think
to take acting classes
what it was was i ran into somebody
who was a comedian who got seen by
somebody big and had never taken acting
classes and they handed him a [__]
script and he didn't know what he was
doing
so he was telling me that story and he
had this look on his face like he
[__] up his whole career so i was like
well [__]
i don't ever want to have that that look
on my face
so um
you know i just uh
i started taking acting classes so i
remember before i took acting classes
bobby kelly was like dude
come over to my apartment dude we'll do
some scenes dude so you do something
dude before you go over there dude
and i was like all right cool
so i went over there we did some scenes
from american buffalo and i have not
read the [__] thing since then this
is one yet another thing that was like
close to 30 years ago so anyways i saw
it
it was the the play starred lawrence
fishburne
sam rockwell
and this kid
darren chris
and they went out and just [__]
killed first of all i went into the
theaters that uh
circle in the square
is what they call it
i guess square meaning times square
i didn't see a circle but i remember a
long time ago i went there and i saw
true west
with philip seymour hoffman and
john c reilly
so that's pretty cool
you know
as far as the actors i've seen in there
philip seymour hoffman john c riley
lawrence fishburne sam rockwell
and this new up-and-coming kid darren
chris is [__] amazing
um
i remember i walked in the theater
immediately second i walked into theater
i saw the whole setup and everything i
felt like this real [__] excitement
like this is gonna be awesome
it's gonna be [__] awesome
and uh
you know [__] lights go down
place is clapping and [__]
then it gets quiet
and the lights come up and [__]
lawrence fishburne's on stage and like
literally i mean i was like at some
points walking around the stage i was
literally like you know
10 feet away from the guy i'm like
that's [__] lawrence fishburn
i've been watching that guy since
apocalypse now
boys in the hood the matrix [__]
decade after decade after decade of
[__]
incredible work
and he's doing this you know the big
opening with darren
and they're both killing it and then
[__]
sam rockwell comes on like [__]
like a bolt of lightning and then it
just
it go it was so it went by so goddamn
fast it was [__] amazing absolutely
incredible
hilarious dark the whole thing
um it was awesome and i was actually
thinking like wow this is [__] cool
man i'm in new york and i'm at a
broadway play
watching amazing ass it's like you know
sometimes you know i just come to new
york and i just feel like
you know i do my little small town [__]
this is where i get my slice of pizza
this is where i get a smoothie if i'm
trying to be good
i'm going out of the club and go do a
spot the same [__] i've been doing since
the [__] 90s but every once in a
while i actually do some new york [__]
i remember thinking like i'm in new york
right now at a broadway play watching
[__]
three of the best actors i've seen in a
[__] long time
um
made the trip feel like you know like
worth it
um but i highly highly recommend it it's
it's going until
july 10th
you know and if you're one of these guys
where you're like dude i'm not [__]
going to some see some [__]
some uh you know [__]
you know schooly boop [__] little
stupid-ass [__] broadway play i'm
telling you if you if you're one of
those guys you hate the theater go see
this [__] you won't
you know you bring your wife down there
she's [__] happy
take her out to dinner
you know you go in there she gets a
program
she gets to dress up
and all of that [__] she watched a great
play and guess what
she won't be mad at you for at least
[__] you know 36 hours
then something will happen but you know
for those 36 hours
i just want to say that was really nice
you know we should do that more
the whole thing the dinner dressing up
just being out just us like connecting
again
it was really nice that's that's the
only thing that stinks is when you do
something nice like that now they're not
yelling at you but now they're
commentating about what the [__] you
just did
you know and then we came to the street
and it said walk and we walked we didn't
run
we just walked was like we had the time
we went up to the ticket booth we got
the tickets
you know and that lady in the ticket
booth was so nice she like all right
i was there
okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry i had a good time right and
then and then you're back into it again
um
so anyway uh i went out and did stand-up
last night went out to the new york
comedy club and i popped in at the uh
comedy seller
and um
yeah i was trying out some new [__] it
was classic new york you know new york
comedy club is the first time i was
doing it it was kind of going okay it
was kind of going all right and then i
[__] went over the seller now i'm
doing it again
within the hour
and it gets just that much better it's
[__] fun man
it was a good
time
um although new york comedy club i
always feel a little old when i'm there
it's a kind of a young crowd
and i was doing my [__]
and um
it was just one young woman in the crowd
was just like staring at me blankly
like who is this old idiot saying all
this [__] ignorant [__]
and uh you know the old me
would have said something
would have said hey lady
you know the [__] is your problem
but i'm old now and i'm like i know what
she doesn't have a problem she's normal
she's looking at some bald orange idiot
up here
deliberately saying a bunch of dumb [__]
i always do it kind of went in there and
i was [__]
making fun of abortion rallies and
feminists and stuff just right out of
the gate just to kind of like sort of
feel them out
if they were going to be like laughing
or whatever and they they were they were
actually pretty good it was part of me
actually i was tempted
to take the night off which i didn't
which i did not because i knew i needed
to do my act
a little bit so tonight when people are
actually paying to see me i'm not going
up there [__]
you know shaking the dust off for the
rust off whatever the [__] expression
is
uh but i was tempted
you know both the mets and the yankees
had a home game last night and the mets
i just saw him play the dodgers but i
haven't been to their new you know their
new city field i've only been to last
one game i went to we should still at
shea
which was a painful place as a red sox
fan to go to
he's always looked over at first base
and you're like
right there that's what happened look at
home plate that's where the pass ball
was
right there and then right there was
where the [__] you know
behind the bag
and the mats win it you know
um
that owner is [__] hilarious
he spent the most money in the league
and he's in there playing like
some of the best baseball in the league
and he's still talking the trade
deadline hey you know if i get to
[__] do something else i'm going to
do it
which is great
and he finally learned from their older
brother across the [__] river there
that's what you do you spend more money
than everybody else um i was actually or
i was gonna go see the yankees because
the way they're playing with their
record and everything it reminded me in
1998 as much as i hated the yankees i'm
like great this is greatness and i got
to go see this [__] team
um
and i did neither and i was also like
this is stanley cup final tonight
colorado avalanche versus the [__]
tampa bay lightning who are trying to
attempt to become
repeat [__] feeling coaches
i didn't watch it
i went out and i did the god damn i'm
trying to guilt you guys right now
i went out and i did the goddamn work
can you say that about yourselves
um
i heard it was a [__] unbelievable
game i walked by a bar when i was done
with my second
spot it was three to three with like six
minutes to go in the third period
and um
colorado won it in overtime
and uh one of my buddies was [__]
text me going dude this is like such a
high level sick level [__] hockey
um
[Music]
all of my friends are picking colorado
just saying they're too fast on all of
this type of [__] but
i don't know tampa's got this the third
time and
i don't know they got a defense and [__]
i just always feel like that experience
on a defense that's going to be tough to
beat but
i am rooting for colorado
i don't know why actually this one i'm
not i'm not really [__]
either way on this one i will tell you
this stamkos goal against the [__]
rangers where he shot it and then it
went off his body and somehow went into
the net that was one of those [__]
[__] plays that you can't [__]
there's no way to prove that he sort of
guided it in but he did
he absolutely [__] did
the first thing i thought of was reggie
jackson when he was stuck in that
rundown
and he [__] leaned his body
his hip you know and he [__] made the
ball go out in right field and steve
garvey's [__] pointing at him and of
course the ref didn't see it ref didn't
see it because it's the [__] new york
yankees
you're in the bronx she wanted to get
out of there alive it was the late 70s
summer is sam [__] this
[Laughter]
um
yeah i thought that goal was [__]
but there was there's no [__] way to
prove it
it's just like
it happened so fast i get why they
called it a goal but it was like he shot
it it went to hit him and he just angled
his body at the goal
and uh but it was great it was perfect
because he didn't [__] slap at it
with his hand he didn't kick at it with
his foot he just sort of [__]
got his body you know
squared up with the net
and physics did the rest
um congratulations to the rangers though
even though it was a [__] brutal loss
or whatever but i mean
they seem to be uh
headed in the right direction and what
blows my [__] mind is they ended that
54-year curse and they're almost coming
up on 30 years already
since they won it the last time
it's unreal they're more than halfway
there
curse was 28 years and 28 years they're
[__] 20
they're 28 years they're halfway there
jesus christ time is flying over e
um
don't say that the montreal canadiens
haven't worn it in 29 years
which was just unheard of when i was
growing up those [__] [__]
they used to win it like every year and
then the 80s they still won one the 90s
they still won one so it's like all
right well now that there's 30 teams in
competition
for these guys they'll win it once every
[__] 10 years
and then i think uh the two
the 90s was the first decade they hadn't
won a cup
since the 1900s they wanted one in the
teens the 20s i mean numerous teens 20s
30s 40s 50s 60s 70s
80s no 90s 93 they won what the [__] am
i talking about
2 000 they want to win a whole almost a
whole [__] century of winning at
least one championship
in a decade holy [__]
holy [__] everybody the old sports nerd
who can barely skate backwards is
[__]
geeking out over here
um
anyway
red sox are winning you know what's
great is nobody's really noticing
because the yankees continue to win they
have such a huge lead on us but what's
[__] great thing is
it's just still the wild card
so for all the winning the yankees could
do
the red sox could still make the [__]
playoffs
and come in there and break their
[__] hats
i mean
last time the yankees peters in the
playoffs was 20 years ago
19 years ago how [__] nuts is that
um
i don't know this team this team they
got this year jesus christ but the red
sox i don't know i've said our
pitching's looking good devers is uh
deborah's i always want to call him
divers deborah's is [__] hitting some
home runs i think it's going to be all
right there by the way i'd have to say
the oakland a's uniform might be the
best in baseball
i know you have the yankees the classic
pinstripe or whatever
which is a great uniform and a great
logo
you know but i think a lot of it is
associated too with the success in the
players which is a part of it but i got
to tell you if you didn't know [__]
about baseball
that [__] green with the yellow and
the white of the oakland days is unreal
you know when you combine that with the
fact that i feel the oakland raiders
have like the best [__] uniform and
logo in all of sports
you know especially with a white jersey
with the silver numbers
it's [__] incredible
both of them played in oakland and now
it looks like both teams well one's
already gone both teams are going to end
up in vegas who the [__] is going to go
to a goddamn baseball game in las vegas
i don't know about that move football
yeah
we just got to sell out eight games
degenerate gamblers love the bet on
[__] football
i mean that was a no-brainer but then
again who would have thought hockey
would make it in [__] vegas i don't
know
i have no idea but um it's looking like
they're going to [__] move
that's such [__] too that really is
[__] [__]
it's like the guy trades away his
[__] team every year or tries to win
with like not doing anything like
spending no [__] money
and now you know
the fans are gonna pay for it
ooh build me a [__] stadium or i'll
even you have a stadium you [__] [__]
it really blows my mind that they can
[__] do that to cities
the [__] that people can do take over
the food supply
pour [__] in the water supply dump [__]
in the [__] ocean
you know
fire hundreds of people at a corporation
while you take a [__] nine figure
bonus
hold the city hostage build us a stadium
where we're [__] leaving
you can do all of that [__] nobody gets
in [__] trouble
then you send out one tweet as an
individual not doing anything and they
[__] destroy your life
um master class everyone you know
with masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace learn to barbecue
bbq from aaron franklin
skateboarding from tony hawk
or learn songwriting and producing
from alicia keys
is that really her last name what are
the odds her last name is going to be
keys and she plays the piano
you know i'm billy strings i'm one of
the great [__] master guitar players
out there
oh yeah i'm mikey crockpot
i'm going to teach you how to cook um
with 100 with over 100 classes
from a range of world-class instructors
that thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think
masterclass is accessible on your phone
web or smart tv offering classes on a
wide variety of topics all taught by
world-class masters at the top of their
fields
each class is broken out into individual
video lessons usually around 10 minutes
long
alicia keys just sitting there right
being all brave without her makeup on
teaching you're
you're [__] you're sitting there with
your little keyboard in your kitchen
buddy
you're [__] there with alicia keys
i wonder what song she teaches you how
to play
um
hundreds of video lessons from a hundred
plus of today's most brilliant minds are
available anytime anywhere on ios
android desktop apple tv
amazon fire tv and roku
i highly recommend you check it out get
unlimited access to every master class
and a monday morning podcast listener
and as a monday morning podcast listener
you get 15 off the annual membership go
to masterclass.com burn now that's
masterclass.com
for fifteen percent off masterclass
um i remember i took piano lessons when
i was just failing miserably the first
time i lived in l.a i took piano lessons
for like i don't know two or three times
i always wish i stuck with those things
because there's always there's a lot of
pianos out there you notice that like
you always walk in and you're like [__]
i wish i wish i s every time you see
you're like [__] i wish i stayed and
stayed with that
get sit down right now like bill murray
and groundhog day
bang out a few hits
um
[Laughter]
i know how to play a couple songs
on the piano i can play the beginning to
um
that journey song
don't stop believing
i think i do all yacht rock
lionel richie
easy like sunday morning
oh yeah i'm coming with the hits people
and i'm starting to [__] with chicago
saturday in the park which for the
longest time i thought was about drug
addiction
i finally looked up the uh
the lyrics
i thought initially was about a guy
going to the park
you know
sort of enjoying what he was seeing
and
like a homeless guy
you know a saturday
or as they sing in boston say
in the park
think it was the fourth of july
people laughing people singing a man
selling ice cream
singing italian songs
and i've been waiting such a long time
i'm like waiting for what
the saturday it's like is he meeting his
dealer i just never understood it it's
like well you know the [__]
time flies by
and then the the second verse i always
thought it was
something about a fog
it's a different word i don't know what
the [__] it is i looked it up
yesterday i forget what it is
but i thought he was singing the word
fog and i thought he was like you know
now his life was going by him
because there's something about chicago
like even their happier songs
you know
when terry cath was still in the band
um
there was like a melancholy to him
the [__] always felt like uh
i don't know what it was it felt like
heavy like
which isn't like a light i'm trying to
think
of the other songs or whatever
but there was just something about it
you know the horns would come in and all
of that type of [__] it just always got
to me oh speaking of that
like horns and all of that and like sort
of minor chords and [__]
my daughter is ridiculously into charlie
brown
and i can tell you this like there's no
[__] way
it's just because it's old like what the
[__] happens to that dude i saw one the
other day this [__] kid it's
valentine's day
and he goes to school with that
i can never say this word
attache
attach a [__] briefcase right
because he's anticipating
he's going to get all these valentines
now i don't know why he's doing this
because nothing in his life has ever
worked out
like this kid is a sad sax sad sack
right
he's on the mount rushmore sad sex so
the poor bastard shows up with this i
don't know spoiler alert right he
doesn't get any [__] valentines
and he keeps checking in with the the
kid who plays piano
he could probably take a master class
from schroeder right
he's checking in with him he's like no
charlie i'll let you know you know no
one's written you yet and he's [__]
sitting there
expecting
the world to show him love when i just
never see people always
yelling at him calling a blockhead he
doesn't really have like they're not
your friends like i sit there and i
[__] watch them i'm like charlie
these guys are not your friends you
gotta [__] punch one of these kids in
the face and get a little respect
your little big-headed [__] right but he
never does it so the [__] little kid
he never gets a valentine i really felt
bad for him and he goes home in the last
second he gets to his mailbox
and he looks in
like maybe there's gonna be one now if
this was a modern-day
pixar movie
he would look in and there would be one
but this wasn't this [__] was made when
we were [__] fighting in vietnam
you know
they had cured polio only like 10 years
ago people [__]
i know lightning life was harder i don't
know what the deal was he [__] opens
the mailbox there's no valentine in
there he gets pissed
he slams his [__] briefcase down on
the mailbox and then goes to kick the
post and he hurts his foot
somehow they brought it around where he
was sort of happy towards the end but
like when it was valentine's day and
he's going to school and he had that
[__] briefcase and you just know
what's gonna happen
but you still have the hope just like he
does like when he goes to kick the
football every time you're like well
maybe like you know
maybe he'll get one he won't get any and
then in the end maybe he'll get one and
it's like nope
nope he doesn't get [__]
and we're gonna take you slowly and
painfully through this whole [__]
journey
um
it's funny because my my daughter
doesn't like really intense scenes and
movies or anything like that even in
like these pixar movies
especially if anybody dies or any
whatever the [__] you know that lion
king thing like she just doesn't like it
and she just tells me to shut it off but
for some reason she can sit
through the unbelievable depressing
episodes
of charlie brown i will tell you and i
will go to my grave saying this one of
the great [__] scenes in animation
history though is when sally
yells at [__] linus
for ruining
her halloween because she didn't go out
and get any candy instead she sat in a
pumpkin patch
waiting for the [__]
the great pumpkin
and she was waiting such a long time
for the great pumpkin
um and then she just lets linus have it
you [__]
she was she was calling him a blockhead
but she was like basically you [__]
[__]
could have been going out there getting
candy and you went in and you know
dragged me out to this [__] i
[__] believed you and there was no
goddamn great pumpkin and now
everybody's gonna laugh at me
and you know what to linus's credit he
just he sat there and took it
he knew he was wrong
there's a lot of hair issues on that
[__] show
you know
massive amounts of [__] alopecia i
mean charlie brown looks like he went
through like chemo
um
i mean jesus christ you know how can can
you just give him one [__] valentine
um sorry anyway that is the uh podcast
i'm on my way out to wilkes-barre
um
[Music]
to do some shows and then i'm going up
to uh i'm doing a show out in a field in
upstate new york where i i think it's
the same place where they had uh
woodstock
dean delray is opening up for me that's
what he said
and then i ended
in uh new jersey
at this amphitheater that i played
back in 0506
on the uh opium anthony uh
traveling virus tour
now that doesn't seem too long ago but
that was like
that was like 16 years ago we get it
bill you're old jesus christ all right
okay so that's the podcast now we got
some interlude music here man and then
we're gonna play a bonus episode of a
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast from a thursday
afternoon
a few years ago all right have a great
weekend you constantly i'll
uh i'll see you on monday
hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
june 16 2014.
how the hell are you how you doing
you know are you enjoying the [__]
summer
when does this summer start officially i
know it's june 20 something i'll tell
you about that global warming it's
coming out to tell
um
i gotta watch the volume this week okay
i have to keep it low
[__] key because uh i'm actually
recording um
sunday june 15th i'm in uh salt lake
city
i go i didn't pronounce that salt lake
city i'm in a hotel room here and i got
to keep my uh
my voice down because i don't want to
offend
you know whatever mormon is next door in
the whole that hotel room right with his
[__] 22 wives or whatever the hell
they do
you know you know what's funny when you
come out here to utah you think what
you're going to see is you're going to
see a bunch of mormons
right walking around dressed like
they're on little house in the prairie
and you know one guy with like you know
four wives five wives
and uh i don't know how many times i've
been out to utah but it finally dawned
on me that if you have five wives
okay
and you know each one of them wants to
have like two kids the average woman
wants a couple of kids right i'd like a
boy and a girl you know one of each
you know looking at you like you possess
that sort of like trick shot sperm
like like are you playing a game of
horse
all right you got to make the shot from
over here and over here one of each
then you move on to the next round so
that right there if you have five wives
one of each right if you're gonna have
kids once a boy and a girl you're
looking at ten kids you're gonna have
ten kids five wives
i mean how many bedroom houses are gonna
have to buy basically what i'm saying is
the reason why i've never
run into one of these people with all
the wives is there's no way they can
afford to live in the city
you know
you'd have to buy you'd have to rent out
a whole floor of a [__] condom uh
skyscraper there condominium
uh co-op if you will
so that's what it is that's where they
are man they're they're over the [__]
hill
they're over the hill so i guess i'm
never gonna find them so you're probably
saying well bill what what do you run
into when you go to salt lake city uh
it's it's absolutely beautiful bit of a
bit of a scary landing here
um
the city itself seems to be surrounded
on at least three sides by a mountain
you know like the old denver broncos
horseshoe shaped stadium
where you know when they'd go to kick
the field goal you could see the parking
lot on one side and then all you saw was
a bunch of [__] orange painted
maniacs on the other
um
by the way i never understood why they
did that the the horseshoe shaped
stadium
it was i just always struck me as such a
half-assed job where it's just like why
don't you just finish the [__] thing
you know or just keep
bleaches on both sides
have it be
symmetrical
you know
i actually know somebody builds a lot of
[__] and
he sucks he's good at it but he sucks
that he wants to do everything himself
and protecting the identity of this
person but
the dude redid his [__] kitchen and i
walked in and i'm lo i'm eyeballing the
cabinets and
you can see clearly one of the cabinets
is like an eighth of an inch or a half
an inch
like it just looks weird you can tell
that it's longer than the other one and
the guy's like i you know i don't i
don't like symmetry i'm not i'm not into
symmetry
thick in my head i'm not
who's not into symmetry
i can see in landscaping it doesn't look
natural if everything's symmetrical on
both sides i get that but when you're
building something
to say you're not into symmetry isn't
for all my construction fans out people
in the
construction arts
isn't what that person's really saying
that they don't like to measure or they
don't like to go back and fix their
mistakes so they just sort of plow ahead
that's basically what this [__] thing
looked like and all i'm thinking is okay
if that's what the cabinets look like
what does the electrical look like
you know
and i immediately wanted to get the [__]
out of there
but anyways let me back up for a second
here um so when you come out here
to utah uh yeah so they got they got
like
i think it feels like it's it's
surrounded on at least two sides
all right
like that winnipeg football stadium that
i saw that i guess they're either going
to tear down they had bleachers on both
sides nothing in either end zone and it
just looked cold as [__] if you went to
the game
um
so it's you know and especially this
time of year when it's uh
when it starts to get hot out
i don't know why but like it tosses you
around a little bit as you're coming for
a landing
and uh so i'm on the plane
and this [__] lady in front of me
might have had the worst tattoo i've
ever seen in my life and it went all the
way across her back
it was like this
it was green ink it was some sort of
tree
or some sort of something it's like
jesus christ we get it you know you're
[__] you like nature
i i don't understa it's like i like the
bruins but i would never get a giant bee
put on my back
why'd you do that it stands for bill and
the bruins
no it stands for [__] [__]
um it was just a horribly
horribly like uh
you know my parents left when i was four
years old just drawn like
you know my buddy who sells meth
you know did this tattoo and i've
noticed that there are
a lot of tattoos out here a lot of bad
[__] tattoos so if you're if you're
on that show
what does it fix my tattoo
tattoo mistakes whatever the hell it is
that one where you guys always draw all
the flowers
over you sending me sam [__] daffy
duck in the ass whatever somebody
decided to get on their butt cheek
right you come to utah
i mean i don't i don't even know why
would you just further [__] the thing up
i guess the i guess because you're
trying to draw something over it that
that makes it creative
i mean i think that they should just
paratroop a bunch of people in here
who are in tattoo removal
you know
and i just have like you know when they
drop the tanks in with that flat piece
of wood underneath it just have the
tattoo removal machine and you set up a
tent like mash
and you just have all these people come
in with that awful green tattoo
tattoos and you just remove them
and then you immediately take them into
another tent and you start showing them
uh
you know just video footage
of what a good tattoo looks like
you know or maybe some art
or maybe give a plane ticket and you get
them to travel
outside outside of these [__] trees
so they stopped drawing them on their
bodies am i being too judgmental am i
well maybe i am
i don't know you know what this is this
really has nothing to do with the
[__] two women that i saw in utah
with those tattoos so i judge all
[__]
you know whatever half a million women
that live in the greater salt lake city
area has really nothing to do with it
has to do with the fact that i am taping
a special
a stand-up special
uh this friday night in atlanta at the
tabernacle three theater uh two shows
and um i'm getting [__] antsy so i'm
lashing out of people not so i apologize
to
you know the 99.5 of
salt lake women that don't have [__]
green tattoos
[Laughter]
i'm also being a [__] because i haven't
boozed since the day i came back from
france
which was uh
april 18th
um coming up on [__] 60 days or
whatever
i'm working out
i look good but i i you know as far as
you know best i can do at 46. okay let's
not get crazy here okay
um
i uh yeah i just want to take this
[__] thing so um i got two more shows
tonight here in salt lake city at wise
guys which i got to tell you man
underrated
underrated for the week wise guys comedy
club
in salt lake city utah and from what i
heard joe rogan's coming out here in the
next week or so
um i guess dave attel was out here and
went on rogan's podcast
and uh joe's great podcast and you know
and dave was raving about this place so
joe called up the next day and i guess
he got a booking out here and uh
so
i don't know man i i got it i can see
why david tell was raving about it it's
just it's perfect
if i can see it's a [__] perfect
comedy club that the ceiling is at the
exact rate height the way people are
seated around you
the way they drop the checks the whole
[__] thing is just great um if i if i
was actually gonna design a comedy club
did you just ask that from your [__]
uh elliptical machine you know what i
would do i would do everything that they
got there at uh
at uh at wiseguys the only the only
thing i would change i would have i
would design it with the green room is
right off the stage
that way if it was a mean crowd and
maybe only you almost got into a
physical confrontation with somebody you
have the option of not having to walk
the gauntlet and go through the crowd
you can just step right off stage and
you're right into the green room much
like the punch line in atlanta
which is great although you can't lock
the door as far as i know
but it's still nice there used to be a
comedy club in new york city
called comics
and that thing was a [__] fortress i
guess you could run through the curtain
but even then there was a door down the
end of the hall you you walked off stage
and you stepped down and immediately you
were in a hallway if you went to the
right you could go out and say hello to
the crowd or you could go to the left
and you could disappear into the green
room and uh you know this week i haven't
been coming out after shows just because
you know
i got my special coming up and uh you
know you go out you shake a bunch of
hands god knows people did god knows
what
is all over their [__] hands after
you shake
a bunch of hands and uh i can't be
getting sick this week so
um so whatever that's what i've been
doing
this week
been eating as perfect as i know how to
eat
you know
as i know that's the key thing is i know
how to eat because i've only partially
read up on nutrition
but uh i'm trying to go veggie the whole
time i'm out here
and uh
eat a bunch of beans and all that
[__] [__] i gotta tell you here's my
pet peeve about veggie restaurants
two things
one um
when you look up vegetarian restaurants
the amount of times
that it comes up with like i guess
i don't actually explain this to me why
do i always get like chinese restaurants
and thai food restaurants
and to me it's like okay i get that
there's no meat in that dish but this
salt is through the [__] roof
and don't get me wrong i love thai food
all right
chinese food i don't know
i don't know all right chinese food's a
little shady in my book
um
but like you know i like eating that's
that [__] you eat you know when you're
just like let's just [__] who gives a
[__] let's eat this food you know
it's like when i on when i asked the
[__] siri there robot lady there my
phone
you know and i asked i said vegetarian
restaurant salt lake city like all of a
sudden all these these chinese and thai
restaurants come up and it's just like
can't you tell i'm trying to eat healthy
i don't need a bunch of [__] noodles
with salt poured all over it that's not
what the [__] i'm trying to do i'm
trying to get down to my fighting weight
here
so anyway so then i i had to go in like
vegan restaurants that type of thing
here's my pet peeve with vega [__]
restaurants the goddamn things
have weird hours
all right
i there's two of them within walking
distance in my hotel and neither one of
them is open sunday neither one of them
is open every [__] burger joint from
here to [__]
colorado springs is open
it's goddamn vegan restaurants how can
they not open on sundays you know what a
lot of carnivores would say it's because
they're too weak they they can't they
need to rest on sunday can't click and
take it yeah yeah nothing gives you less
energy less energy than eating in a
healthy way
that's i am so [__] sick of that [__]
and people talking about electric cars
like could they go up a hill you know
that's why i'm really i'm starting to uh
i'm starting to pull away from the whole
conspiracy theory thing i think the
whole thing just works itself
you know
because there's just enough people out
there that don't don't know [__]
myself included jesus christ
i'm top 10 on that list and you just
it's just it's uh yeah it's really not
like a group of people living under a
mountain it's just a bunch of
mouth-breathing morons
or not even people who just don't
[__] know anything
you know
like i've been talking about i want to
learn how to fly a helicopter and people
keep saying
you know what do that man
those things are falling out of the sky
all the time
really
and everybody's okay with that
just every other
mary can't come in to work today yeah
helicopter fell out of the [__] sky
did it happen to her again i mean don't
get me wrong it [__] happens it
happened in scotland this past year one
fell on a bar
horrible story but i mean obviously i
mean [__] happens
okay [__] happens [__] happens on the
ground too
you know how many times a day do people
step on a rake right
does that mean you leave the leaves out
there and burn up your grass i don't
think it does
do it if the [__] engine cuts out you
know that's it
you're [__] done you just drop like a
stone
no you don't
you don't
jesus [__] christ look it up
just look it up all right you [__]
auto rotate
[Music]
like i'm saying that like i know how to
do it
um although i have watched people on
youtube do it it's pretty it's pretty uh
it's pretty [__] impressive but
whatever
whatever look my brain is all over the
[__] place this week i
can't stand the weight the week of to do
my special all right i am i am ready
right now i'm actually sitting here in
my boxes
and my t-shirt and i am ready to throw
in some slacks and a shirt and if i
walked out my hotel room and they just
passed me a mic and i began my special
nothing would make me happier
all right
this is it's like it's like i just want
to get out there and [__] do this
goddamn thing
because the second it's over
oh [__] red face is on vacation
i'm on vacation everybody for the first
time ever
i'm taking i'm taking this up basically
taking the summer off i've got a couple
of gigs here or there but i'm i'm
dialing it back
you know and by taking off the summer i
mean i'm not going to be jumping on a
bunch of airplanes i'm going to be of
course
in the comedy clubs out here in l.a
trying to build up my next hour before
my next special comes out but i'll be
sleeping in my own bed
i'm going to be getting drunk in my own
house
i'm going to be putting on all the
weight that i took off from my special
in uh neighborhood restaurants i'm gonna
have a great time become an old billy
fat face again
you know right now i'm malaria william
now don't get too skinny
i love people say that to you don't get
too [__] skinny it's like if i lifted
up my shirt and you saw the horror show
that's underneath it you're just used to
me being
really out of shape now i'm only kind of
out of shape all right but believe me
calvin klein will not be calling me ever
you understand which really disappoints
me because i think it's about time they
did a spread
uh of a 46 year old redheaded male
shirtless okay
so if they're listening
all right i'm throwing my [__] hat in
the ring
how bad
how bad would this stock plunge
yeah you never know
because i used to watch uh
watch that top model show with nia you
know i mean i got to find a middle
ground so it's like if you're going to
watch
some reality at least i can look at some
you know
beautiful nine-foot women
walking around with a look on their face
like you know somebody peed in their
okra
right
and uh
so many of them they they had beautiful
bodies but their faces they were [__]
weird
so i finally said to me i'm like you
know what the [__] is what why
what is with her [__] uh she looks
like she put on an astronaut helmet
that was too small you know and she left
it on for like 24 hours and i just just
popped the thing off right now
you know and she's just like well you
know tyra likes
she likes them she thinks they should be
a little weird looking
i was just like what why is that
so she doesn't feel intimidated
you know
what's her problem she's been on the
cover of sports illustrated or she
trying to help other people because
people used to make fun of her forehead
you know i love that people made fun of
tyra banks's forehead you know like if
she came walking up to you right
doing that thing with one leg stepping
over the other leg for some dumb reason
i you know something i have to be honest
with you no matter how good a woman
looked
if they came walking up to me
like that doing the stepping over each
other foot each you know every other
foot whatever the [__] i'm trying to say
right over left left over right with
that look on their face with their hair
blowing
um that's supposed to look so amazing
if that actually happened to me in real
life i would be sitting there looking at
them
do you guys ever see young frankenstein
you know remember when gene wilder's
going it's alive
it is the life
you know
and frankenstein's just kind of sitting
there looking at him like the [__] is
wrong with this dude that that's how i
would be looking at i'm not saying
you know that they're not beautiful but
whatever i'm i'm [__] making too many
left turns here
i don't even know how i got to this i
was talking about weird-looking oh yeah
so i i'm weird-looking
i'm a weird-looking [__] who knows
maybe it could have i don't know that
does that work yeah i guess it does work
i was thinking maybe it wouldn't work
are women into weird looking guys
and not from my experience
no kidding uh
i was kidding who you know what are they
into they want they want security
and that translates to money because
that's how the [__] world works so
are they really [__] i don't know when
we return
and i'm all right i'm gonna pause here
now
actually don't have my advertising so
i'm gonna have to record it later and
drop it in so right now i have to pause
so i have a place to [__] edit this
into all right
legalzoom everyone america was built by
innovators and dreamers
people like thomas edison and henry ford
laid the foundation for our country
these days it's the inventors and the
entrepreneurs all around us like you
that keep our country running by fueling
the job market and economy this month
legalzoom celebrates innovation by
helping you launch your dream apply for
a patent to secure your inter your
invention register your trademark to
protect your products and services
incorporate or form an llc and launch
your business visit legalzoom.com and
use discount code burr b-u-r-r they'll
provide the personal attention you need
and help take care of all the details
they've helped over a million businesses
get started
right
and they've received an a-plus from the
better business bureau celebrate
innovation with legalzoom today and get
a special price on trademark copyright
or provisional patent applications by
using the discount code bur b-u-r-r at
checkout legalzoom provides legal help
through independent attorneys and
self-help but they are not a law firm
legalzoom.com discount code burr
and lastly but not leastly
hulu plus everyone you've probably tried
hulu on your computer hulu plus is so
much more with hulu plus you can watch
current seasons
uh episodes of your favorite shows like
modern family the daily show and scandal
and watch every episode of shows like
nashville lost and doctor who
you get ad free movies and kid shows too
now more than ever there's so much to
watch
take total control with hulu plus to
stream these shows and thousands more as
much as you want whenever you want hula
plus works on your computer your
smartphone tv
roku apple tv i'm sorry your smart tv
not smartphone smart tv roku apple tv
xbox playstation pretty much
any streaming device you already own you
can even watch on your phone or ipad
well i guess they can then huh while on
the train at work at the dentist or in
the bathroom you can even block off a
data bench
you also get to uh to access originals
that you cannot get anywhere else check
out the new show deadbeat a comedy about
a pot smoking guy who talks to ghost you
can binge on all 10 episodes starting
april 9th for only 7.99 a month get your
shows anytime anywhere that's like a
quarter a day come on folks sign up now
right now sign up at huluplus.com bill
or click the banner on my website and
get two weeks full access completely
free that's a whole extra week more with
this special offer when you sign up at
huluplus.com
bill
oh wait i've got the ending so get with
it and start streaming tv now with hulu
plus
i'm the worst
okay and we are back
we are back i hope you enjoyed that read
i hope i did a good job on it
all right
because i'm reading that sometime in the
future um
so anyways i've been uh you know
with my [__] add i've been trying to
learn how to you know
just work out more efficiently or
[__] whatever so i've been eating
right and that type of thing and i've
gotten into all these uh you know i like
climbing the rope and doing pull-ups and
[__] and i stumbled onto a couple of uh
youtube videos
of course i don't have them up here but
i'll definitely send the links to uh to
andrew to have them up here
um a couple of these home home gyms you
could have in the garage
and um
and and one this one it's actually part
one it's a three-part series where this
guy teaches you how to do a muscle up
which is basically if you ever saw
somebody do the pull-up and they
basically
go past their chin up to their chest and
then basically
get to the point where they do a dip at
the top of the bar the the the the other
half of a dip
because you don't have to go down
because you start i just explained that
in a completely confusing way you know
what i mean you shoot past the bar and
then you push yourself up
with your arms so your arms are then
straight at the top of the bar
and i remember the first time i tried to
do that if you could have listened to
the this
remember when uh
what's his face william wallace was
getting his entrails yanked out
[Music]
okay remember that noise mel gibson was
making
if you could [__] take that audio and
then turn it up
to uh you know when they do the
chipmunks holiday uh records that's what
i sounded like when i tried to do one
aside from the fact that i completely
lack the strength
uh my technique
i didn't understand
that
very little of it is your arms going
past that uh that bar and i'm not even
gonna try to
begin to explain i will my head i'm
supposed to be funny on this why don't i
try to explain it
it's basically
you're coming up when you're when you're
pulling yourself up you sort of explode
up and you got your legs are a little
bit in front of you and then right as
you you got your chest up to the bar you
do a quick sit-up in the air i swear to
god which causes your legs
to swing down like down past you like a
[__] pendulum and you actually roll
up onto the bar
so it's really
it's your abs sitting up and then your
legs swinging up from underneath you
that gets you up over the bar and then
your arms are in positions positioned to
uh
to then push yourself up and it's like
oh that's why i was [__] up so i
figure
i figure if i just you know
train doing that for two months
over the summer
trying to get my technique down
right
and then i somehow uh you know jump into
the cocoon pool i had to be able to do
it by 2016 what do you think
maybe do the human flag one of those
[__] things i'm just fascinated with
people that have that kind of strength
and i found uh
i don't know you just click on that then
the other things that they suggest i
clicked on like five others and all of a
sudden i was watching these guys
climbing what was considered the hardest
rock face to climb in the world
and these [__] guys
i mean i [__] about doing pull-ups you
know i got my whole hand around that
these guys got like that you know that
little joint at the top of your finger
they're hanging on like that
and they jump up to a thing and they're
like for their fingers that last little
joint grabbing some little crevice
and i'm telling you they reach up and
they grab it and you and the people on
the ground hear him all the way on the
ground you hear him the guy jumps up and
grabs me just here
they do that the whole [__] way up
they got a grip called the pinch grip
just imagine holding a dictionary a
really thick book right and you just
sort of would hold it straight down you
know on either side of it you're just
holding it by the binding yeah like that
kind of a grip like the lobster grip and
the the thing is like it's
uh
it's it's faced up and down what's the
[__] word perpendicular i have no
idea it looks like a nose coming out of
the [__] cliff and they jump up and
grab one of those and then just pinch
with their [__] hand
and then they got one little toe and a
crack below it just holding that
i mean watching these guys do this [__]
i swear to god it's like these guys
i mean i i don't know like
if you ever had him in prison it's like
how long could you keep him in prison
the second you got him in the yard you'd
have to have a [__] scope on him at
all times because they would just
[__] run over to the corner
where one wall meets the other wall and
he's a little 90 degree turn
they just kind of
all the way up the top of it next thing
you know that thing be right in your
face like that [__] grizzly bear that
ran up that tree if you seen that
youtube video this guy's sitting he's in
a [__] tree like a bow and arrow
trained on this black bear and the black
bear looks up and sees him and within
two seconds it runs up
the tree next to him and is above him
and they're sitting there like going
dude what the [__]
holy [__] what the [__] they're like
freaking out
and um
i don't know why
i was rooting for the bear
i wanted the bear to maul that guy
i just think it's [__] up to go out
and shoot a bear or an elk or a moose
you know what i mean can we just keep it
with cows and chickens
isn't that enough
fish and all the fish that get [__]
killed i swear to god
i swear to god the more the more i i
i don't know i look into that [__] it's
it's just brutal you know where i go
hiking in uh california when i hike and
by the way i do wear short shorts with
aerobic socks when i hike
there's a [__] mountain lion
there's a mountain lion in the canyon
and that's been freaking me out and they
have these cameras set up all over the
place and over the last couple years
they've taken pictures of them they just
took a picture of the thing recently
and i swear to god it looks horrible
and what they're speculating had
happened happened is the thing is
eating coyotes that eat rats that eat
the rat poison that people put out
you know to kill the rats
and if you saw this thing you know i am
terrified
of getting mauled
okay i'm terrified of the ocean getting
eaten by a shark
getting pulled out by the riptide and
getting mauled any of that [__] [__]
any [__]
that involves me
i just can't imagine
when one of those cats
is you're walking right just reaches out
and grabs you okay
just and turns you into like this
ragdoll how little [__] control you
have
your ability to fight back it's like
dude you're fighting [__] edward
scissorhands
but fast
you know or like freddy krueger on all
feet just that alone you ever get
scratched by a [__] house cat
it [__] kills
can you imagine a goddamn mountain lion
just grabbing you and pulling you over
to its [__] mouth oh god feeling that
breath on your neck
jesus christ i'm [__] terrified of
those things that's just the mountain
lion which is like a house cat compared
to a tiger right
so but i saw the thing's face it's just
like that's that's
terrible it's [__] terrible man so
i don't know i'm not trying to get all
peta on you here i know what i'm talking
about i'm all over the [__] place
this week um
so anyways i really want to get you guys
those clips because uh
there's three clips i want to show you
that have really inspired me
to try and get back and you know
i don't know
if you just stop walking around with
this 15 pounds of pizza and beer weight
just [__] sick of it
you know i've knocked off like half of
it
i just don't understand how far down i
gotta go to have a flat stomach again
you can't even do it once you be once
you get that [__] belly
it's just over you try to [__] lose
the weight and you just lose muscle in a
matter you eat a whole goddamn chicken
somehow your [__] arms are going to
shrink and your belly's just going to be
sitting there laughing at you
jiggling
you know
you know it's funny i actually got a
[__] email this week
and i know you guys think jesus bill you
have made a major body issues yeah i do
well you know what why don't you get uh
get
get on [__] comedy central's premium
blend why don't you do that and then get
yourself a [__] twitter account let
me tell you what kind of body images
you're going to have people aren't
exactly nice to you
um
they start off nice hey really funny
[__]
but what's the deal with and then you
end up getting like oh [__] i never even
noticed that about myself so anyways
here's somebody says uh
fat shaming bonjour guillaume french for
william all right i actually knew that
one shimmer belgian
uh
raymond
i am a long time listener and i love the
show i am a big guy and fat shaming work
works it really works last september i
was sneaking a pizza in my car while
listening to the show and you had
another rant about fat people and you
basically described exactly what i was
doing like you you were somehow watching
me eat it made me laugh uncontrollably
and i decided to get serious about
losing weight i quit boozing which is
something your show inspired me to do
and ate healthy and exercise twice a day
i was off the bottle from september
until february and spending the holidays
sober was quite a challenge but i got my
weight down from 310 to 254. dude
congratulations
what is that let's do the math here for
this guy 61 pounds
times five miles of capillaries for
every [__] pound
that's 305 miles of
less
of capillaries that your heart has to
beat every time isn't that wonderful
we'll be right back on dr oz sorry
everybody i was pleased with my progress
and i started working out less and
resumed drinking until mid april when i
weighed myself at 273 so i gained 19
pounds in about two and a half months of
drinking i was shocked therefore i am
off alcohol again and and
and weigh 243 now
holy [__]
he says my goal is to weigh 210 before i
drink again please continue to make
criticizing uh
oh please continue to criticize the fat
asses because you do it in a hilarious
yet respectful way thank you for your
help
ah dude that's great man you know what's
great about what you did was a lot of
people if they went from 310 to 254 and
they started you know going back to
their bad habits you then you know gain
it all back and then some i'm surprised
you weren't 320 something so the fact
that you actually uh
got back on the scale at 273.
shows uh you got a lot of willpower then
you dropped another 30 after that
so what are you down all together 243
that's 57
and 10 is 67 pounds dude that's amazing
man that's amazing uh
well if you go back to boozing what i
would suggest is uh
drinking whiskey or scotch meat
you know or drinking vodka in the rocks
or something just
it's kind of that's like the vaporizer
of boozing
you just get right to it like all those
chick drinks
um
not only you do you you're sucking down
you get a brutal [__] hangover first
of all and then it's just all this extra
[__] you know rum and cokes
you know you have five rum and cokes
would you ever sit down and drink five
cokes
i can barely finish one after a while
since i can feel my stomach expanding
like i'm in some hot dog eating contest
um so yeah i would go i would go back to
that and then um
i would somehow limit
uh your intake of it which i got to be
honest with you i don't know how to do
because
uh speaking of boozing
okay there's a segue for you
um
so here's the deal i
basically said i wasn't gonna drink
until my special so i i'll be done with
my special
friday night
and then i was kind of thinking like
well you know what i want to close out
june
you know because i didn't drink for the
entire month of february or may
and if i get june then i'm kind of
balanced out right i drank january
march and april didn't drink february
may and june so i'm kind of you know
i'm [__] got the yin and yang
of being a drunk douche and actually
being sober
but uh
the thing is is the last
weekend
in june i'm at uh i'm at the mirage in
las vegas
and it's not gonna be hard not to drink
you know because i don't i don't gamble
you know what i mean i'm too [__] old
to go hang out and do that type of [__]
if i'm going to booze i would just go
back and drink by myself in the hotel
room which is i'm not going to do
however
excuse me i had to take enrique water
there um
coincidentally and i don't know how this
happened the all-in tour
starring joe bartnick
jason lawhead
and paul
don't say i'm from new jersey versi
is going to be there on the sunday night
i'm there friday and saturday i can't
[__] believe it they're going to be
right across the street
you know
so what am i supposed to do
what am i supposed to do what what i'm
not going to hang out with them
you know what's funny that's going to be
like june 28th or 29th
and uh
what am i going to do you know i got to
do it so i'm going to go over there and
i'll tell you what's funny as i've been
dying for some miller high life
there's something about the bottle i
don't think the beer tastes that good
it's just the best bottle ever
you know looks like a [__] lady
[Music]
and there's a part of me
to relate to you sir i don't want to go
back
i miss it man i [__] love drinking
but
uh i like how i feel not drinking
but um
i don't know man as i said diversity
before
whatever the [__] i said about the devil
in me the devil is uh
devil is rearing his [__] ugly head i
can't remember what the [__] i said to
him but i i feel it like i i need to
what i'm hoping to do is just get
absolutely plastered with them and then
immediately go back to uh
sort of uh
not being an idiot and then actually
doing these workouts that i was telling
you guys about and you might think i'm
obsessed with this stuff but i am i mean
who wants to be a fat [__] nobody
you know don't you want to be in good of
course you do all right i don't need to
get into this [__] with you guys
you know you're a bunch of adults
um yeah i fat shame myself all the
[__] time
and it [__] works all right well
let's get beyond this let's let's move
in a different direction
let's read another uh wait before we do
that i haven't even talked about
anything let's how about let's talk a
little bit of hockey
all right
first and foremost
all crown the la kings the kings claim
the crown
second time in three years you know what
was weird is i thought the blackhawks
were going to win it and they were going
to say that they were going to be a
dynasty
okay if they won three because that
would have been 2010
2014 13 2014.
so
they would have won one
they would have won three in five years
and they're saying how competitive with
all the free agent signings and all that
[__]
um three and five years would now be
considered a dynasty so guess who's in
line for next year
the unthinkable the la kings a couple
years ago you know actually more than
that four [__] years ago
the la king fan base was thinking are we
ever gonna [__] win one i bet if you
talk to their fan base they were
probably going like dude i just want to
see them win it once they just win it
once in my lifetime i am going to be
happy yeah yada yada yada yada and here
we are four or five short years later if
they win it again next year that would
be let's see they would want it in uh
then chicago 1415 they would have won
three in four years where they gave the
patriots a dynasty so that would
definitely be considered a dynasty no
unbelievable what a [__] team
you know and i also got to say hats off
to the rangers because everybody thought
like the east was a lot weaker than they
were and despite the fact that they lost
in five games
i mean
three of those ranger losses were in
overtime um
i definitely think the kings were
clearly the better team but i just being
a you know a bruins fan i was happy that
the east
you know we didn't get absolutely
shelled the only tough game it was if
you arrange a fan to watch was that game
game three when they lost three to
nothing where they really just got shut
down
and uh game four i missed because i was
working
uh i think that's when the rangers won
two to one but whatever man it was great
it's a great season and uh
jim rome actually tweeted something
where he said uh
you know once something to the i
retweeted it something to the effect
that once again the nhl playoffs just
show you know just saying that basically
that they were the best playoffs now i'm
not gonna be someone who says that i
mean i think they are but i understand
if it's not your sport but i'm telling
you it's [__] insane um but however i
have also been watching the nba finals
and i actually watched both conference
finals and i've been enjoying that too
and uh how about them spurs
looking to close it out and you guys
know whether they did or not
um
i won't know because uh it's the [__]
afternoon here by the time i post this i
don't know who the [__] knows all i know
is uh
it's been amazing to watch the spurs
[__] great team how about that
leonard kid jesus christ
you know what i like about him
the one clip that i saw he shows up to
the arena
looking like he's gonna go play
basketball
as opposed to everybody else who for
some reason show they show up like that
they're gonna [__] foreclose on
somebody's house
why do they wear the suit it's like if
you're gonna wear the suits then you
want to do it like uh
you know walt frazier
you know and i'm using that reference
because i actually uh i'm gonna get a
little hollywood on you but i'm doing it
because uh promoting
a friend of mine's
uh um
new documentary
uh michael rappaport was nice enough to
invite me to the premiere of uh
screening of he's got a new
documentary out
called when the garden was eden based on
uh a book by the same name that was
about the 70
um and 73 new york nick championship
teams and basically the building of that
championship team and
um there's a lot of overlap when i
actually you know just knowing some of
the rangers history the same thing where
um
the knicks just weren't even respected
and that same thing just like the new
york rangers like right around when
playoff time came around madison square
garden also brought the circus in and
the circus would sell more tickets
than the rangers of the knicks would
and uh so they would have to play like
one year the new york rangers
i forget who the [__] they were playing
i think they were playing the detroit
pist pistons the detroit red wings
jumping sports here
the detroit red wings in the stanley cup
final and the circus was in town and
madison square garden wouldn't let them
play their home games
in madison square garden so they
actually hadn't played i believe it was
in maple leaf gardens where the toronto
maple leafs played
they considered that somewhat of a home
game because leaf fans hated uh wings
fans and they thought that leaf fans
maybe would show up
and root for the rangers
um there's a lot of that type of stuff
you really should see it if you get a
chance i don't know i don't have a
premiere date yet but i'm going to try
to get him on
the podcast again longtime listeners
remember his last
his only visit to the podcast where he
trashed me for the giants beating the
patriots in the super bowl and all new
york fans of course enjoyed enjoyed that
go [__] yourselves
but um
it's it's a [__] amazing documentary
and one of the funniest things about it
without giving anything away is
listening to rappaport trying to bait
these guys into trashing boston
and their fans it's [__] hilarious um
so definitely check it out it's gonna be
on he did it was one of those espn i
don't know 30 for 30 60 for 60 i don't
know what the hell it is but it's it's
amazing it's called when the garden was
eaten all right
is that my horn out enough things this
week
you know how about this i got another
one for you that i actually watched
downloaded legally paid my five dollars
i watched david spade's new stand-up
special called my fake problems
um
definitely check that one out what i
loved about it was i actually you know
it's still his
you know classic david spade but i felt
it was really personal stuff
um
like i it's easily his best special he's
ever put out so if you're a fan of his
or a new fan or a curious man it was
definitely worth the five bucks
um
and that that's one of my bucket list
things i want to see that guy live at
some point but anyways let's get back to
the uh let's get back to the podcast
here um
what else what else have i been doing
here
been watching some world cup soccer my
[__] tv just went out in the hotel
room so i was watching france
they were up three n three to nothing
two
two uh zero whatever the [__] you say
zero and uh
i don't know i i get into the world cup
i think it's [__] awesome and i do
think soccer is a beautiful sport uh i
just don't understand why my my
complaint that i've always had with that
[__] sport i don't give a [__] about
the lack of goals [__] i watch hockey i
still understand i just think it's
awesome i just don't understand why
every [__]
two minutes somebody collapses to the
ground like they blew out their acl and
all they did was get kicked in the shin
and they have a shin guard there
now i'm not saying that i wouldn't
collapse to the ground but i'm not a
professional athlete you watch the
[__] ufc those [__] maniacs kick
the other fighter with that part of
their leg now i know they come in at an
angle but it's still their shin now if
they can toughen their leg up to do to
do that
you know i don't understand why these
guys
can you make the [__] guard go all
the way around their legs so we can keep
the movement going so i don't know i
mean i i don't know
my idea of watching a sport is not every
two minutes i see a man a grown [__]
man in the fetal position
with a look on his face like he's going
to start crying
and then somebody comes running up to
another player gets right in his face
like he's going to punch him and you're
like oh great there's going to be a
fight and then he takes out this yellow
card and sticks it up in the air like
he's in some benny hill sketch
other than that i love it the scarves
the singing people going absolutely
[__] nuts when they score i enjoy all
of that so i'll continue watching it and
this year is actually great too now that
they uh they got it away from those
crazy horns whatever the [__] are those
things we're called
oh jesus what's who the [__] calling
me now huh who is this
oh jesus
hang on the lovely nia everybody nia i'm
recording my podcast can i call you
right back
okay sweetie all right
um
anyways
where are we
here 43 minutes in i could tell by the
way she said okay that i need to talk to
her
she's like okay
oh geez
all right um what was i talking world
cup soccer so i have no idea who's going
to win that all i know is i think that
you know
i think i've watched enough soccer
to tell to know that you know the united
states is definitely without a doubt
going to make the finals this year
if not win the whole [__] thing
okay
look i know they're not gonna win it but
i just
i want them to win it so bad
because it would piss off the world on
two levels one everybody [__] hates
us so they're not going to enjoy us
actually winning a true world
championship where everybody was invited
and we were the best and then secondly
when like 40 people show up to the
parade
you know
here in the united states
just to watch everybody having to wait
another four years to wait for their
team to win it and just see that we want
something that we don't even give a [__]
about right
like some hot chick that gets a [__]
you know a bentley for a [__] 16th
birthday
oh my god why did you get that color i
guess that's okay
you know that would be us if we ever won
the [__] world cup and i want it to
happen
i really do
um anyways the same way i wanted my team
to draft michael samp and i wanted to
absolutely dominate because on two level
levels it would annoy fans one that
someone on my team was dominating their
team and then two all the homophobes
would be upset that this gay guy was
just wreaking havoc
all right oh speaking of soccer
uh dear billy world class
um oh actually you know i gotta pause
here to reach read some more [__] uh
sorry guys to read some more [__]
advertising this is the last little
group here
let me do my little pause
all right
who's number two in the
order uh dollar shave club everybody
the big razor companies you know what
they think we're stupid
oh yeah every year they roll out some
ridiculous shaving technology gimmick
and expect us to shell out big bucks for
it what are they up to 17 blades at this
point
all lifting and separating like a bra in
the 70s
do you really need a razor with a
vibrating handle
huh a roller pivot ball back scratcher
egg timer laser pointer corkscrew
huh i know i don't
we were shaving just fine before any of
that crap we were two blades that was
all you ever needed
um you can get it under your nose they
got so many blades you can't even shave
under your nose
um and i definitely don't think i need
to spend my hard-earned cash on it
people it's a bunch of junk if you're
sick of being treated like a fool like a
[__] like an idiot a [__] a sucker a
chump join the hundreds of thousands of
smarter people who join
dollarshaveclub.com
dollarshaveclub.com delivers the best
blades and grooming supplies for just a
few bucks a month their blades are
better than the big shape companies for
a fraction of the price you know what i
have sensitive skin so watch what you
say about it when you're around it and
their razors have never given me any
problems honestly i have the best shave
of my life with their 4x razor you got
to try it i've never used that stop
putting words in my mouth i like the
double blades you got there sweetheart i
told my buddy about the dollar shave
club that would be you guys and he
shares a subscription with his wife no
lie i think it saved their marriage
dollar shave club why are you writing
all this crap you have a product that
sells itself
quit trying to make me sound more
personal all right
it's personal the way i [__] up the read
okay
my listeners can get started now at
dollarshaveclub.com
and don't forget next week is [__]
father's day
upgrade pop shave upgrade is
wait upgrade pop shave with the dollar
shave club gift card because he
shouldn't have to pay more for his
ridiculous shaving gimmicks either stop
getting ripped off by the big getting
ripped off by the big shaving companies
join dollarshaveclub.com
uh shave club
duck what
oh they wrote it three times in a row
with no punctuation
dollarshaveclub.com
then it says shaveclub.com
i don't even understand what it is
dollarshaveclub.com that's what it is
burr okay
this it's legitimate
we don't need any bells and whistles on
this thing just join it okay unless you
want to keep getting screwed
all right if you like to be gillette's
prison [__] keep doing what you're
doing oh god look at that look at that
little
thing i just opened up those are my
french words i stuck with it for two
months now i don't remember any of them
okay and i'm back here all right um
all right soccer dear billy world class
uh i don't hate on soccer even though i
have a problem with it there are some
great things about the game sometimes i
wish i played it because it
automatically it would mean
i'd have great hair and abs apparently
uh what pros and cons would you say
there are to the game of soccer i think
i already answered this
i you know i just love how
the whole world loves it and we don't
love it and then we have the nerve to
sit there criticizing it rather than
sitting back going hey maybe we're wrong
about this
you know
like the whole world's on like the
[__] metric system and we're we're
not you know i know we're gonna stick
with the uh the foot in the [__]
yachts
so uh
anyways let me hear what your complaints
are um
let's see he says uh
my biggest complaint other than the
pratfalls and wussy injuries is that
well dude i gotta be honest with you if
somebody is running full speed and steps
on your your foot with the cleat i mean
that's gotta [__] hurt i mean that's
up there that's like taking a wrist off
your laces
um is the fact that the refs control
when the game ends they don't end the
game until a play is over despite what
the clock says
uh no that's that's the uh penalty
minutes for all those guys rolling
around on the ground
to have you relate to it that's like a
snow day
if you get a snow day in like elementary
school you still have to go 180 days so
they just tack on an extra day you were
going to get out of school on june 20th
now it's the 21st that's how it works
they keep track of the time
he says however in a game yesterday i
watched
uh possession change twice and a yellow
card being issued
uh
he puts in parentheses someone stubbed
their toe and the ref still didn't stop
the game you think nba refs can mess
with the game the soccer refs got a few
weapons of their own
um
yeah i guess yeah i guess they can i was
when i talk about that i talk about the
four major american sports united states
of america what i'm talking about but uh
yeah i guess you can give people yellow
cards
give them two yellow cards but i feel
like the crowd
kind of keeps the ref in check
where you know
like an nba ref
can consider player
and uh you know
i don't know if it was a big enough game
maybe he'd get a couple of death threats
but you know
in the soccer world they'll actually
carry they'll actually kill you they'll
actually run out into the field
and like [__] saw your head off
um
there was something horrific that
happened down in uh south america
with this like 20 year old ref
first of all he had a knife on him so
you can tell what kind of a [__]
horrific refereeing job he knew he was
going into
and he got into it with some guy and i
don't know what happened but he took out
a knife and he stabbed this guy
and i believe the guy died and then his
brother
the dude who died's brother and
everybody else ran onto the field and
they cut the dude's head off
on the [__] soccer field
you know
and we flip out when ron artest goes
into the crowd
and throws 15 punches and doesn't
connect once basketball players are the
worst
they can't throw a [__] you know what
it is it's because they were nine feet
tall in the third grade they didn't have
to fight
and some of the shorter guys the six
foot ones you know they knew how to
fight but i swear to god
first of all they throw punches like
they're trying to throw somebody out
from like the warning track they do that
overhand [__] ah a lot of them a lot
of them they uh
i don't know what the deal is
that would be [__] scary right if you
actually learned some martial arts
i know kareem abdul-jabbar tried to act
like he did
in those bruce lee movies or maybe uh
wilt chamberlain
and
uh conan the barbarian
did he fight in that thing or he just
sort of sit on that [__] yak
i can't remember
um anyways i don't i don't really uh
i'm not gonna criticize uh
i'm not going to criticize world cup
soccer the whole [__] world loves it
i understand that there's something
wrong with me and you know i went to a
game when i was over in england went to
that arsenal game and uh not a lot of it
was the [__] it was the [__] we just
don't have enough time
to get into it
you know like i would say if you if
you're if you're into uh sports in the
united states you're into football
and you're into basketball for them or
you're into football you're into hockey
all right and maybe you watch a little
bit of baseball that's how that's kind
of where the pendulum is right now but
there's very few people that can
actually watch hockey and basketball at
the same like the the amount of space
that would be taken up on your [__]
dvr
right
i used to do it back in the day though
back in the 80s man
when we had bird mikhail
robert parish
you know [__] uh dennis johnson
cedric maxwell
mlc
right and then the bruins
all through the 80s the ending of stan
jonathan wayne cashman terry o'reilly
into cam neely raymond bork
right gord klusak
willie plett lyndon byers all of those
[__] guys you didn't want to miss a
game
at least i used to just
that's all you did
just that during you that's why i suck
so bad in school aside from the fact
that i was dumb
was
you know
the beginning of the year school year it
was football season so that [__] half
my weekend
right through january and by january i
was in the throes of hockey and
basketball season that [__] ended around
may and then it was june and then i was
just like you know maybe i'll try next
year
you know and then what happened then i'd
go to summer school
ah summer school
what a [__] great time that was once
you just got past the fact that you were
still going to school what you really
what you realized that you were now into
this
you boiled like it's like when you
reduce something by heating it up and
you basically they boiled off all the
[__] nerds all the people that
applied themselves and what you were
left with was this high concentration of
class clowns and absolute psychos and it
was the i mean it was the best [__]
it was like going to a goddamn comedy
camp
and where
i went to summer school it was like
three towns
so you met these class clowns
from three different towns and everybody
kind of had their own [__] style
and you had to up your game
i know i've told these stories before
i they were just a
time the guy poured the coke out on the
guy mowing the lawn
during the break and we all ran and we
sat down and then our [__] teacher
came in he was wearing bermuda shorts i
swear to god i think they were pink
he starts to lessen and all of a sudden
the guy who was mowing the lawn comes in
he's got he had on a white t-shirt and
the coke had made brown stains all over
the front of it he just comes barging in
and the [__] bermuda short teacher
looks at him like what the [__] he goes
hang on a second and he walks all the
way to the back of the class and he
sticks his [__]
he had a square and rectangle head all
at the same time like a fred flintstone
head he sticks it sideways through you
know those school windows and then looks
down he sees the puddle of coke right
underneath the window and he's like yeah
this is it
which one you threw the coke out at me
and we're all just laughing
laughing our ass off and then uh you
know the kid who did it admits it he
doesn't give a [__] he's not afraid of
the principle
you know he's on a first name basis with
the guy and it was just like
it was a great time
other than losing your summer you know
blue's kidding hope you know my redhead
was gonna be out there sunbathing
um all right continuing on
all right uh this is somebody talking
about last week daughter or gay son
[__] question from last week uh
dear billy friend of gay
i'm a gay male and a listener a listener
most of the issues that come up in
everyday life pertain to the gay
community are overblown i came out in
the early 90s i was a bit more emotional
and defensive about things back then
because the climate was very aggressive
towards gays
um the truth is we only have a re we
have come a really really long way it
doesn't mean that the prejudice is gone
but it's a place where
they're
what where i think where the general con
consciousness of the country is in a
much healthier place
um last week a reader
asked who uh which you'd have a [__] of
a daughter or a gay son
um let me start off by saying that i
love nia and i can see why
you do as well sometimes i think she is
a bit hard on the listeners and quick to
label label them as caveman
um i got to tell you this
for you and everybody else who thinks
she's too harsh and you guys just know
this she's not talking to you guys
all right she's talking to me
because she knows how i am and she knows
what the [__] i say this is what you got
to understand she lives with me so when
i shut the mic off or whatever i come
home from a comedy club she hears the
[__] that i say and i'm just like you
guys i say all kinds of [__] that i've
actually had a real job
you know i'd have to issue some sort of
[__] apology you know what i mean
because i'm a human being and i'm a
[__]
so
what she does is she thinks she knows
all the [__] that i say
um most of which ends up on st and
ends up going to the stage i usually end
up taking to the stage because she gets
so mad at me
and uh
i still oh you know you know what one of
them was
this is actually a great story sorry
guys i'm [__] in this high altitude
and i just worked out and uh
i keep getting [__] dry mouth here i
know it's disgusting to listen to me
drink here i'm sorry
um
all right here's a classic one
that bit i did about rihanna
um
about saying you know i'm not i'm not
condoning what the guy did and
but like
you know
i was basically speculating what
happened
you know what happened in the car before
that [__] went down i can't remember how
the [__] bit went so i'm sitting
there
and i say that [__] and she just goes
don't even [__] say it don't eat
because of right when the story came out
don't even she was doing that [__] you
know when somebody's so mad at you they
can't even look at you she was putting
her index finger up
like
going like hang on a second she was just
sort of looking up with her eyes closed
don't even say don't even [__] say
and i just start laughing
and i of course
you tell a comedian don't say it you
know they're gonna [__] say it it's
like that mr saturday night scene billy
crystal
when he does that what's with your
[__] hair when they said don't say it
then you gotta say it
so uh so i said whatever the [__] i said
and then she got so mad at me or
whatever then we had a giant debate
about a surprise surprise
and then like a week later
completely unprovoked
my mother-in-law was over
and that story came up again
and she goes you know that's terrible
but
i got to admit
i wonder what she said and i start
laughing and he is just like mom and i
felt totally justified and whatever that
ended up being that bit or whatever so
getting back to what you're saying she's
not she's not calling the listeners
cavemen so don't don't i label them as
cavemen she's really talking to me
because she thinks i'm a [__]
and then she thinks on the podcast that
i am a pied piper for morons she doesn't
understand that the amount of people
that listen to this just to listen to
how dumb i am
and laugh and feel better about
themselves or maybe get fat shamed
anyways back to the uh the question hand
here um he said however uh it is her
opinion and i've never thought her wrong
for it
this guy's being very diplomatic
in this case though she was way off the
mark
there was nothing discriminatory about
the question in fact it was the exact
opposite it was oh man i wish he was
here for this
it was an inclusive it was inclusive and
represented the types of thoughts a man
having a son could have raising alarm
the way she did
sensationalizes some issues that don't
even exist we do not have chronic
problems of wondering which sex we'd
rather have
be a [__] the fact that the question
was intended to be humorous humorous
which she did acknowledge put it in a
category of even less offensiveness
um you of her have made many jokes about
a million things and implying this is
off limits victimizes the sexual habits
of either sex uh her intent was
righteous uh but it it's
this irresponsible alarming of any issue
that makes it harder for a gay boy to be
thought of equally and also makes it
harder for a straight person to become
comfortable with issues pertaining to
sexual
uh
orientation p.s you look better with a
beard
[Laughter]
oh [__] you know right as i was about
ready to say that this was my probably
the most
grammatically like
best written thing on the podcast
you could have you could have read that
on [__] meet the press you gotta yeah
that was perfect you set me up but in
the end you took a nice [__] uppercut
um
i like having a beard i also like being
clean-shaven so you know i'm sorry
you're just gonna have to keep looking
at that poster of me above your bed sir
okay because i'm going clean shaven here
for a while all right
hear that clean shaven all right fat
shaming i already read that one
um what are we up to here oh we're up to
an hour um
graffiti hey billy copper crotch ah gee
look at that just taking [__] right
to the left here
is this any way to treat your host
you know i invite you over for free
i help you with your commute and here
you do [__] trash in my pubes over
there
um
first off i'd like to say i'm a huge fan
of the podcast oh i know how this goes
yeah butter me up so then i put my guard
down and then you [__] trash my
[__]
i don't know what my giant forehead
he said always hilarious even even
insightful at times oh look at that even
dummy's right every once in a while uh
gets me through the long commute to
college every day he said uh jesus
christ this kid's 18 years old oh it's
even insightful
you little [__]
um he said i'm an 18 year old from
providence rhode island
i've drank there
i've been into
art uh ever since i can remember i love
all forms of it except those dumb ass
sculptures that look like some [__]
welded a couple of scraps of junkyard
metal together in a pathetic attempt at
being uh creative
uh but the one form of visual expression
that has always been my hat
and personal passion is graffiti
um
ah man the question got cut off wait a
second wait a second wait a second i got
it right here hold on hold on hold on as
a graffiti writer
i am very aware that many people despise
what we do
consider it pointless
ugly detrimental to society as well as
childish yet i have been utterly curious
to know what your opinion slash position
of our art form is be it negative or
positive i'd be ecstatic to hear you
discuss it on the podcast for a bit for
a bit best wishes to the lovely nia
and you you old [__] go [__] yourself
dude everybody's trying to steal around
this week you know i feel like i'm
winning and all of a sudden you [__]
sugar rate lended me here
um
ps you should come perform somewhere in
rhode island connecticut or boston soon
me and my older brother have been dying
to see some authentic billy boy stand up
but we lack the finances to travel
relatively far from home well i'll be
there definitely uh
as i build up my next hour i haven't
been to boston and uh i think it was
february of last year so i'm do i
definitely do
um
all right so what is my what is my
opinion on it i i definitely think it's
an art form i definitely like any art
form there's some i like more than
others
what i my only complaint is the canvas
that you guys use
i respect the ability to uh
i mean some of some of the like someone
who actually makes like a painting or
something like that is incredible just
sitting there tagging and writing your
name then it comes down to how how
visually
i guess stimulating it is
but my thing is to uh
what kills a lot of it is if you
actually
spray paint on something that i was
already appreciating and the fact that i
know that somebody else owns it and that
you just spray painted all over it i
understand that a lot of that art is
this outlaw thing
um
[Music]
you know i mean i don't give a [__] you
know those metal things that they pull
down over the doors those are ugly to
look at so when graffiti artists spray
painted them i thought that those look
better however you know if you come up
like where i live
you know there's these guy you know i
don't know this [__]
armenian gang and they they
tag [__] all the [__] time
and it stinks it's just black spray
paint and they just spray their [__]
thing
it's really dumb they write danger in
one of their things which is really
stupid and i i've told you before that i
think armenians and russians are the pit
bulls
of uh
of human like i would not you i would
not [__] with either one of them on any
goddamn level however i will sit there
in the safety of this hotel room in the
middle of utah surrounded by mormons and
say that that that's kind of [__]
lame
to write danger um it's just stupid now
baiting them to do something dangerous
but uh
yeah i don't know i i would say it it
i've seen documentaries on uh
uh you know graffiti artists and i
definitely have an appreciation for it
but i i'm happy that they're off the
subway trains in new york
um
i always hated that [__] then they
started scratching up the seats and [__]
and it's just like isn't it awful enough
that these things are going to be filthy
because so many people are in here do
you have to [__] ruin it now by
scratching up the windows and all this
type of [__] and like
i don't i don't you know all that
[__] that they say well you know
i guess with some inner city kids they
have this you know they feel invisible
and this is their way of of what [__]
ruining property that's i don't know
there's got to be a better way to do it
but i have to tell you out in l.a
there's some amazing amazing stuff
that i have seen so uh i don't know
so i guess yeah i do appreciate it but
sometimes
you know just some of the [__] like they
got a lot of stuff uh
you know la's just classic for just
tearing some beautiful old building down
and then just sticking up a [__]
strip mall
and there's not a lot of stuff like that
left so when there is something like
that some art deco looking stuff and
some kid comes up and spray paints all
over it
um
you know
i don't like that i think then i think
it's ugly
i think uh you there was already a piece
of art and then you [__] like in a
way it's like you're [__] blocking
you're not enhancing it or whatever um i
would say that
you know what is funny though
is when you see somebody driving down
the street
in like some truck and there's just
[__] graffiti all over
that always makes me laugh because i
always think about uh
the griswold family truckster when they
pulled in they went to ask for
directions which was absolutely
hilarious you couldn't do a scene like
that now because it would probably be
considered too racist or whatever but it
was [__] hilarious they pull in and
they're stealing their hubcaps and all
that type of [__] and spray painting it
was basically it was a def jam bit
like what's his face chevy chase was the
white guy
you know hey how are you just trying to
get back out on the highway you know
that type of [__]
so oh you know what i forgot to bring up
here's something else i wanted to show
you guys before uh before i get out of
here um
is i got a new rear end put in on my
truck
i finally i you know
i went out to texas when i hung out with
those guys over at gas monkey they were
telling me because i got still have that
granny transmission in there
and i wanted to keep it you know a three
speed on the column i just think it's
cool as hell to be shifting on the
column
and um
so i didn't i you know
i didn't want to [__] with the linkage
or something like that where all of a
sudden i don't i don't i like i don't
actually to be honest with you i don't
know if i put a fourth gear if that
means now i got to have it on the floor
just always seems four on the floor
three on the tree
so um
one of the guys over there at gas
microwaves yeah just throw a new rear
end in
you know because my truck basically
redlines at about it was at about 50 55
doesn't redline but it's it's making
enough noise with the engines working
too hard
because it's basically designed to uh
just kind of
haul [__] around on a farm
um so whatever so i put a new rear end i
didn't put anywhere in uh
obviously uh they had some other guys do
it and uh
it's [__] amazing
it's [__] amazing and now it's making
me now i can cruise at like 65
which is night and day
you know 55 to 65 65 you you're cruising
at 55 you're actually going to cause an
accident you bump up that extra 10 miles
it's huge
and now um i don't know i think i kind
of got the bug
i really want to keep the truck as
original as i can but
to the point that i've everything that
i've changed on the truck i've kept the
original like when i had an aluminum
radiator put in
i kept the original one i have that in
my garage
when christopher titus helped me do the
the front brakes
uh basically showed me what to do
i kept the uh the drums and the shoes
and all that [__] i have that and now i
have back there i have my pinion and
ring gear from the rear end
and um
i found this great website i gotta find
it that actually explains gear ratios
and how to do them you gotta check it
out it's one of the coolest like [__]
it's one of the coolest things
sites i ever read as far as like
mechanics go
and you really understand like racing
a lot better like
the push-pull of ad it's all about
weight
you know trying to get the car to go as
fast as it can while still keep keeping
it as light as possible
it's [__] amazing that whole balance
um
and just all the [__] that they do to
the car it just makes it i i feel like i
moved up three levels in my limited
understanding of it's really really
[__] fascinating stuff and uh i
already forget how to do gear ratios but
i counted the rings on my old uh ring
gear
and and on the pinion and i was able to
figure out what kind of rear end that i
had
and i was trying to get over to the
garage when they were putting the new
one in because they were going to
actually you know show me how to like
the way titus showed me we're going to
show me some [__] but and of course
ended up getting some crap that i had to
do so i wasn't able to do it but um so
that'll be it i'll show you the rock
climbing thing i'll show you the guys
showing you how to do a muscle up and
i'll show you uh
what else
what i just talked about the gear ratios
oh and then the last thing too just to
keep it fair so it's not all
testosterone stuff i'm going to show you
a a [__]
youtube clip that i saw today
on how to basic it's pretty basic how to
just make an egg within some bread
you know like an egg over easy and this
woman actually makes it with a little
heart shape so you can do it for your
wife i'm telling you this is the type of
[__] you do
that you know so then when you actually
[__] up they have that inner their head
oh he made me an egg in the heart-shaped
thing so i watched this thing showing
you how to do it it's really basic
uh which is why i could understand it
but i have i got to show you this thing
i don't wanna know i don't wanna i don't
wanna bait you guys into writing a bunch
of mean comments
all right there's something in the video
that is super [__] annoying that
you're not supposed to make fun of so i
won't
all right but i'm just letting you know
that you know
there's cute and then there's [__]
annoying and i felt that this video went
into annoying but other than that i'll
put that up there anyways all right but
keep your comments [__] nice you guys
you guys say way too much mean [__] a
lot of you too you guys go way over the
top
you know if you don't like my wife being
on that i get it you can just say that
you don't have to go as far as you
[__] go
to really uh you know i mean that's
[__] up me saying that considering i
trash everything but uh you know
just [__] dial it back a little bit
all right you [__] all right that's the
podcast for this week go [__] yourself
i'm telling you right now united states
i'm praying they make the world cup
final i'm praying that they win it and
i'm praying that 40 people show up all
right that's it go [__] yourselves i'll
talk to you next week
you